this idiot me would rather back by a
woman because of what she chooses to do
with her outer appearance yeah
meanwhile he's deleting tweets from
people asking him to shed light on the
abuse from a prominent hafidh that is
probably his friend for five years ago a
girl called Asha in France 14 year-old
girl was accused of a video circulating
that that was her having dinner with
someone it cost her life she jumped out
the window this is how severe an
accusation and slander is he's worth
committing intercourse he by the way he
claimed that his fault me by the Sharia
said that was supposed yet he came to
the prophet and said this what happened
Allah subhanAllah send our revolution
this journey this road I travel on it
all seems crazy over the years I picked
up thousands and Tagalongs inspired by
my story from a tree for now with my
clothes had holes in them
I'm afro is picky to the night east
maschino a Mossad she writes no laces in
Iraqis new millennium
I said I'm one even what I meant away
better care to be brothers and sisters
and dear friends hope you guys are one
each other I mean I mean this beautiful
garden
what's this beautiful garden it's Moses
bad garden and it was very nice and I
probably very refreshing to be doing
this video here and we can be discussing
very important topics brothers and
sisters before I start I want to please
allah subhanaw taala the most merciful
the most trust or praise His glory and
gratitude belong to him for the work
that we do now recent controversy has
arise in the social media once again
this time it was I got dragged into it
now like I said before guys I'm trying
to abstain from controversy
I'll be honest with you I don't want to
be I don't ask for it I don't go look
for it I haven't found it in my paws
looking for it oh my gosh I mean I don't
do that
genuine concerns that arise I tried to
help him do with it we had a big
catastrophe that happened a year or two
years ago with the whole hasanat issue
and we know what happened and we came
forward not to be saviors or heroes or
it like tried to be you know like with
the hero of the Omar
black what I mean I mean like I'm the
ruler of I'm not you know but we came
why because there was a genuine fitna
and maybe a plot to cause mass apostasy
which was
destroyed by allah subhanho wa taala
hamdulillah now when these things arise
brothers and sisters what happened with
the whole husana issue is what
and some people attacked me oh you
promoted them etc look I have no doubts
that actions that I did back then why
because when the Sharia calls for it we
defend the honor of a person whoever it
is Bravo sister non-muslim when the
Sharia calls for it we defend on and
that's what we did when their owner was
who needed to be defended we defended
their honor and when the Sharia Court so
when the Sharia Court so defending the
honor we defended on hamdulillah and to
evidence it will bring for clear
evidences and this office has to go to a
judge and done to someone who's
qualified not us laymen yeah
and when they should be a code for the
exposure of these individuals we did
that very thing so we're not here
looking for opportunistic things
something comes up here but fallen under
the bars yes this cancel culture yep
find something finished marry him finish
him off it doesn't work like that
depends on the situation recent
controversy Iraq arose because of a
certain re which I'm not going to
mention don't need to mention at all
because from the get-go we cannot talk
from the get-go we can't talk for
against it we don't know what's going on
but a certain party who recites the
Quran was accused of drugging and raping
sisters now this is a massive allegation
this is a massive allegation and what
we're going to go for bombing sisters
for us to learn today is the book
Islamic jurisprudence from share sally l
thousand yes and ulema
a scholar an alum yes I'm the lightest
color that we try our best to get
knowledge from hamdulillah and when we
have this mutant brothers that we even
asked him to go to him but they rejected
that's a different story
let's stick to this very simple topic
and here we're going to discuss some
very important things for us to learn
from now on any allegation that comes
out how do we as Muslims deal with it
this the reason I'm doing this video
education purposes we own ok anytime
with any allegation what does the Sharia
call for us to do allah subhanaw taala
is Cal AM his kitab is what has been
sent as a guidance to mankind and we are
going to judge based on that not me oh
no he should do that execute him kill
him do this
calm down we have a lot and it's a
result yeah Samiha now well time we hear
and we obey now brothers and sisters
firstly before I get onto that inshallah
what I want to do is the following so
this all started with that bond the
sisters so what happened is these
acquisitions will be fun I go in contact
with the friend of the girl who's
accused who's accusing this quality of
doing this to understand the situation
what's going on why because I was
dragged into it Alan you need to speak
XS you like I mean what mean please look
I'm not I mean I mean I'm an infallible
person who has many mistakes I don't
need to comment on everything so I
thought I didn't say nothing about I
just made a few tweets and made a very
general statement people started
tweeting things and the comments section
screenshots now these screenshots that
have been placed there I can't just let
that just roam around because I don't
know even if it's true I don't want to
be a part of this lambda which is a
massive sin I don't want to be a part of
that so I hit the comments the comments
that the Twitter will be made I hid them
so then you got a group of sisters going
on a mad one yes some some sisters right
these intentions but misunderstanding
yeah and a sister with the silver is one
of those but there's a something that's
very more interesting about society with
the silver and her calling me an idiot I
don't wanna do this video critical MIDI
I don't really care okay let's watch it
cause me I'll get called worse stuff
yeah that's the least of my concerns but
there's a very important ironic thing
that happened that we need to mention
and the double standards and hypocrisy
of it we're gonna come to that
so sisters come and said oh you're
hiding the tweets we can see it your you
know your that's probably your friend
blah blah blah why are you hiding it
talking about and what happened
afterwards is that randomly now the
timing may have been bad I saw a tweet
of a girl who make his statements of
disbelief I don't even know she's left
for the way some not sure
free from hijab hash that free from her
job now who uses hash from could have
start from free from a job you can see
on the screen that most of them are
started by X Muslims and free from hijab
is actually an attack
towards Muslim women who wear the hijab
liberate yourself free from hijab you
know whoo-hoo let's live their life and
I made a comment I made the tweet which
you can see on the screen yeah
so my tweet was basically you think
you've got freedom from hijab and you
know some people come and say yeah call
freedom not really all you did is that
he was under pressure most I'm not
saying all the time
generally yeah okay you're under
pressure by societal pressures yes and
the oil the the hyper sexual society
that we live in as objectified women to
such a level that they think the only
thing that they have to offer is their
body parts I'm not so sad to see that
females who have made left Islam whoever
they may be that they think liberation
is get your everything out there I'm
sorry people look at me I was seeing wow
you actually that is the biggest form of
enslavement hyper sexualized society
telling you that you as a human being
the only thing you have to offer is your
body part from the way that you
addressed it arose and this I never said
anything about girls who don't wear
hijab I've not once mentioned that I'm
talking about somebody directly
attacking hijab ease but what's happened
an accusation an assumption an
assumption by who
sister be but the silver so she makes a
on her story she posts the following
yeah so let's read it for ourself
problem sisters so what did she say and
somebody said this by the way I don't go
in her story but she'd even tell me for
me to see it so she takes this out of
context has no idea that this person is
actually attacking the job is I'm
actually defending here jobbies and what
does she say I'm sorry but I can't stay
silent
this idiot me would rather backed by a
woman because of what she chooses to do
with her outer appearance yeah
meanwhile he's deleting tweets from
people asking him to shed light on the
abuse from a prominent Hafidh that is
probably his friend now it carries on
when it's a woman you want to be
sounding your alarm bells but when it
comes to talking about serious going on
in the community from a Muslim man you
want to sinus people and delete comments
I have zero respect for men who make a
career out of humiliation and picking
and choosing what they want to expose
and what they don't want to expose
now this coming from sis happy with the
silver was quite a bit ironic a bit
surprising because I've had discussions
with her recording these massive bomb
and sisters and what did she say next
she says none of these mail online
scholars are in uproar after the serial
rapist in their community is outed but
when they found out hassanis wife was
leading a double life
he jabbed off and they were devastated
make it make sense this obsession with
Muslim woman bodies needs to stop best
aim in this absolute utter nonsense you
know why I can prove that from the works
that I've done and I can prove that for
something that you guys don't know
behind the scenes sister happy with the
silver nose which I'm gonna come to so
now she's made this statement brothers
and sisters yeah okay now what she says
probably his friend what does that mean
now what are you trying to say my friend
is a rapist and I am trying to defend
him I'm trying to hide it it's my buddy
you know I don't feel a lot okay what
law says my buddy my mate here yeah
Johnny here yes I need to defend him who
the hell do you think I am who do you
think I am that I'm going to be
silencing somebody yeah knee how dare
you accuse him and then it alone accused
me firstly he's not my friend in the
context of I'm not trying to clean my
hands off him for another bus no no I
know him I've spoken to him but to say
is a friend like he's not my friend
friend like moose is my friend Matt
maybe job is my friend but what is my
friend you know so when you say
stainless like that I'm seeing the
anybody is guilty until proven innocent
so you've now said his affair I'm
defending my friend and you're here
daring to tell me that I always pick on
woman's appearance absolutely nonsense
show me one time there are fun videos
because the problem is sister be bar
you don't watch videos yeah you don't
watch my videos no one's asking you to
you know watching context when we did a
video for sister being a Tokyo or
whoever it may be we never said how do
you take the job you're going to the
Hellfire
you're finished you're a describe Miami
burn you when I said that me and Musa
actually done a video that got nearly
half a million views where was
encouraging her when she was on the
verge of taking a job or sister Donna
and what did we get back
absolute nonsense and abuse all I see
and I'm not judging entirely but for a
certain people that we've discussed with
in those platforms I've seen nothing but
arrogance stuck-up individuals I'm so
sorry and I want you guys to watch the
video in context because I have done so
many videos advising Bhansali fouseytube
ramification Hasson at the house on that
issue was so much that we was getting
attacked from people saying why are you
not talking about his wife why aren't
you attacking him
his wife was just gonna cry and get away
with it we are being attacked why
because we're attacking has an app more
and we've got people that assist I mean
with the silver calling me an idiot yeah
I'm an idiot because she took a tweet
out of context didn't understand why I
was hiding the tweet yeah which I'm
going to come to about the very matter
you're gonna find out about something
that she knows I'm gonna I'm gonna come
to it yeah she just wants me to go about
it so most of my videos I was the first
youtuber that done a video men's job she
told you I always talk about men's head
job as much as I talk about women's I
have never gone in attacked any specific
individual for taking their job of
unless they are an enemy of Islam and
doing it to attack our sisters and
you're here without clarifying nothing
chuckling you're an idiot you are this
show of that now brothers and sisters
this is the very same sister sister move
in the silver four or five years ago a
girl called Asia in France fourteen year
old girl was accused of a video
circulating that that was her having
dinner with someone it cost her life she
jumped out the window this is how severe
an accusation and slander is so much so
the punishment for me is 80 lashes and
as you can see on the screen a Saudi man
in Saudi Arabia accused his wife yeah
bite because you want custody of his
kids and I said no she's not good enough
to be a mother
she committed she committed adultery and
he didn't even come to court he sent
someone on his behalf to come to call
guess what both of them the guy went him
and the man got their last four eighty
lashes the guy said look I'm here just
to convey said no no no you are also
getting lashed this is how harsh the
Sharia is so who do we go to in
allegations come to Ali no sister leave
the silver no nobody but a lot in his
mess
because we're emotional people oh no
well even in this book here this book
when it talks about judges how judges
should be judges how should we behave
firstly they shouldn't even be judging
matters of people that they know so if
an allegation comes about someone that I
know I am the last person you should
come to because I might be biased or I
might have an infant was you should not
come and there's many examples to this
which I've made notes for example in a
situation of Roma Democrat table this is
the support for him it says my name a
cartographer the case of obey to they
live in fabric to decide it because it
was someone that he knew a leader on the
other hand referred in a rocky mantle a
should I to judge his case and Othman
referred tell her to remain even not him
what if an answer right yeah so these
are people that they know they don't
want to judge because there's someone
they know they said look we can't judge
it you have to go somewhere else so when
these allegations come about people that
I may know I'm the last person you
should come to yes we should talk about
it if it's wrong I'm not gonna show call
anybody well I oak semilla if it's my
mom my dad I don't care if the Sharia
calls for it it's going to happen just
as the prophet sallallaahu Selim said
even if it is Fatima my daughter that
has committed theft she will get the
whole dude capital punishment but we
literally and sister happy with the
silvered knows when I travel to France
even if I'm not mistaken she even
tweeted my tweet to raise awareness to
the very sister who was London and we
went there to defend her honor and Bill
Santa Acharya I don't need a cookie from
everybody but don't you dare comment
insult me for a something that you don't
even know you don't even have full
context to and this is how dangerous it
can be to to to slander somebody and
without any bit I'm not seeing these
people are lying I'm seeing at this very
moment of time first thing you need to
go to the police it is the case you have
to go to the police go to a judge and
let
qualify people who fear Allah deal with
the matter that is what we need to do
and from my videos that I've done I
always support sisters all the time that
I get criticized for trying to be on the
sister side so nobody can ever come to
me and tell me I always be consistent I
advised brothers
Muslim youtubers males more than I do
with sisters so this nonsense
accusations of I'm always doing this
it's nonsense and one very important
thing I want you guys to listen bosses
which is fundamental I'm not saying
these accusations these things are lies
I'm not saying neither are they true I'm
saying I can't say nothing about it
Islamic Lee at this moment I can't say
nothing against it why brother and
sisters there has been people who have
falsely accuse others sisters and
brothers yeah now when these this when
we do this and if it is false it's a
disservice to the future victims what
that means is if these people come out
and this happened to me there was a
sister who messaged me on Twitter and
said this person raised me and this this
this this and I was a Panola hoo-wah etc
and she came out and said you know what
I was doing that tip for attention I was
like what
attention you're accused us of attention
and we know many cases where Joseph
accused the taxi drivers of raping them
when it was absolutely false it is a
disservice to the future cases and
future victims so that's the reason why
we should be very careful because if it
turns out to be false and we jump on the
bandwagon he's this he's that whatever
she's this or whether but whatever what
happens it becomes a disservice when
somebody in the future genuinely is
being raped and whatever's happened then
what happens brother and sisters is that
was gonna take seriously oh just like
other case okay yeah alright nobody is
going to believe them that's why what
I'm asking is the following
I'm nobility in this situation I don't
give a damn who is I would expose in the
context of make out and protect our
sisters and also protect our profits cuz
there's a lot of evil sisters out there
doing evil stuff yeah so I would do for
both that is my point and this is
fundamental for us to understand to
protect future victims that's why I'm
taking this matter rationally logically
not emotionally according to the Quran
and the Sunna now let's come to the crux
of the matter
above the sisters sister be with the
silver I'm sure you're gonna be watching
this you're coming up with this
allegation
you're coming and saying this is serial
rapist what if um what if this was all
false what if I'm saying what if you
just founded a person now let's get dig
a little deeper if you remember in 2017
in 2017 someone that you know sister
happy with the silver someone that you
know there was a video that emerged and
when I'm in video by the way this make
very clear it was an allegation
something appeared I was made a wait for
it sad because I come I'm in the morning
everybody comes to me and send me the
stuff oh look what's going on and with
the silver sphere but uh did I say yes
God could good content for my page now
for my channel subscribers yes did I say
that
no I contacted the Instagram yeah which
you know who it is and I said take it
down see I wash the pan or Tyler
take it down this is an allegation this
is false it's not true yeah don't expose
that person since now what I done for
you in your friend you want me to treat
a new person differently so what for you
and your friend would defended your
honor we try to help you back you would
back you up for the sake of all I don't
need nothing from you nothing from you
your your reply to me on the insta
saying you don't need me to be your word
knight in shining armor
it means sarcastic and calling me an
idiot again in there disrespectfully
just like Dena Tokyo's husband when he
was trying to speak to nicely and we
always speak to these people nicely
Salaam alaikum my sister may Allah bless
you and we get nothing but arrogance
attitude from them telling me oh I don't
need to be like you I don't need to do
nothing for you I don't need nothing
from you I do it for the sake of soup an
Italian halwa and you're there calling
me an idiot again you looking like a
idiot this table you're not my knight in
shining armor and Allah don't need you
I've got my wife I'm I'm a Muslim you
know warrior if you want to name it okay
so so I'm not there to do that but
what's so sad is that you want me to now
go full out and expose somebody based on
your emotions how you for which is
rightly so it's wrong anyone when we
found
Hasaan I was doing this to his wives and
all kind of madness we went full out on
him and you know that's what don't you
dare come to us and tell us that we're
here to cover and sugarcoat don't you
dare
so now when that happened brothers and
sisters we covered it well sister baby
the silver said happy but I don't call
it the silver sister b-bomb yeah in
traversing I've got the screenshot I've
got it there yeah okay when I message
you and may raise awareness to you you
totally glory I don't need you
technology I'm just saying I don't need
it but you knowing what I do for the
sisters hamdulillah
and for an innocent sister was standard
in in in France which you're aware of
and you know that what I did for the
sake of allah subhanho wa taala i'm not
here to ask for cookies I'm only
mentioning this because it came from you
and I'm trying to show the hypocrisy and
you're asking me to go on a full out on
a person but when it was you you was
happy with what I did that's hypocrisy
that's double standards that is a verb
that is oppression not only that his
screenshot of a brother coming and
seeing to me a key you know sister Habib
ah she does just take this kind of
indecent pictures and here what did i do
there are closing here promise in that
to me let's expose her oh I'm loving
this I said and you can see on the
screen beloved sisters here now go to
the screenshots guys here let's go
screen squat in the screenshots somebody
message me it says Salam Brava I see you
talk Adam started due to the factory as
a large Muslim following look look this
is evidence within itself and he's
misguided people but brother makeup art
but the makeup artist lifelong
percussion is wearing clothes which is
totally unexcited especially with the
hijab
that's true that's true but we spend
enough videos on that meta
bass between her and alone if she wants
to carry on doing that like I said
before we she knows what's right from
wrong so what she wants to do in
promoting that what can we do sadly with
advice they don't want to take it we
can't do nothing you know wearing
clothes which is unacceptably with the
hijab and now so many he dragged yours
are wearing tight clothing fingers okay
yes and this comes to our houses the
attitude these things that our sisters
do sadly it comes to our house our
sisters our mothers our wives get
affected by this ugly
imagine if I've done a video about gangs
and violence and it affected your very
brother in your house you will get upset
in right but
when we do is when misogynist you know
we hate women we always talk about the
hijab let's carry on this is very
important that just please stick one
because I'm trying to be failure
unacceptable blah blah but I saw there's
a Bravo talking it ok tight clothes is
it's okay just cuz I may be the Civil
War it so will you consider making a
video about it bro because it really
hurts me for me to see women wear a
hijab then very wearing very tight
clothing next next snap out outlines the
shapes of the body and to think it's
okay when it's totally Haram okay you're
cliche Bravo okay why let him salam may
the peace and bliss will not be upon
this is my reply to him actually the
matter is not that simple
i don't go search for what she's doing I
don't I've got better things to do in my
life from what I know she wears loose
clothing but sometimes a bit tight from
what I know yeah okay not that I go
there and look pictures that we've come
across what did i do did I attack did I
say all great I said Ikey assume the
best assumed the best but no no anyways
I would only talk about it if she starts
wearing really inappropriate clothing me
Ani in the context of y'all now pushing
it out there yeah
this was back to three years ago by the
way my views have kind of changed a bit
for now I'm going to just assume the
best did I want to attack did I look for
it no look what he says Ness next ok
Brava you're the intellectual elite no
I'm not
may Allah increase in religion may I
said may Allah grant you Jenna I just
went through her stuff she does wear
loose clothing okey I'm more concerned
about those who don't even dress
appropriately blah blah blah okay there
are uh okay now he goes broke you don't
have her on snap but it's calm bro you
know best no I don't know best
I said allah subhanaw taala knows best
not me and then he said to be honest I'm
more focused on women who wear hijab but
wear tight cover but I don't want to get
get into that okay I said what does she
do in a slap snap like what are you
talking about where's very tight
clothing and starts dancing etc with
hijab on and I said okay I said can I
ask you a question they said yes bro why
are you on a snap don't be upset but I
want you to reflect upon this we are
taught as men Allah says in the Quran
tell the believing men and the believing
women
don't know why your gazes so we are told
to lower our gates her stuff is for
sisters so if we go and look for her or
anyone else mistakes we will find it if
we didn't follow her then you would have
not seen it do you get what I mean
and the Prophet acknowledged it's a
hundred percent over I'm not gonna even
argue with that and the case was closed
this was sent in 2017 yeah
the message that you see about blood
that I don't know what to see you can
see my attitude assalamu alaikum may the
peace and blessing of allah be upon you
sister just for I'll share this DM i
recieve with you
yeah and there's some stuff that i'm
blood which is private is about a friend
that she knows so brothers and sisters
in a nutshell what do we learn what did
we learn today we learned that to any
kind of accusations and judgments come
you have to make four but you do stay
silent until evidence has been proven
once is proven then you can do whatever
you like okay in the context would call
into the sharia okay because these are a
dream stuff they're so great slander is
such a big thing and allah specifically
mentions slandering a chaste woman is
one of the kebaya the major sins that
destructive since the process in him
said one is to accuse a chaste woman of
adultery so much so called an revelation
was reviewed review to a companion a
remoter companion hell I'll even umeå
yeah it was man of mercy on him that he
saw his wife committing intercourse by
the way he claimed that is for me by the
Sharia says that was most yet he came to
the prophet and said this what happened
Allah subhanAllah sent a revelation
yeah before that he was going on what
seeing them because the the brochure
said look yeah I look Safin Allah with a
killer that you have over your wife
I have no Kira Allah has more Hera the
protector of jealousy but what you are
telling me with no witnesses you are
getting whipped you're getting whipped
Bravo and I'm not talking about the whip
but your wife's have a new promise yeah
you got whip I'm talking about you will
get lashed you will get lost
and he said supernova I saw with my own
eyes he said regardless regardless this
is a massive so kinda accusation if
anyone was to come and accuse somebody
will be finished he did this to me Oh
killing yeah yeah and Allah sent down
revelation to protect this or not to
take photos in the fifth of the a las
Tres be upon the one that's lying the
wife and the husband have to do with
each other to save themselves and surah
noor reviewed why the process Adams wife
was slandered and Allah is so harsh
against those who brought this light and
Allah sent down a ayah Kalam of Allah
sent down to defend the honor of the
process Adams wife and here we are
calling people that we don't even know
yet serial rapist idiot defending him
I'm his friend
fear allah subhanho wa taala and
brothers and sisters it's very evident
from that that we know insha'Allah that
the matter is very very clear promises
in this matter inshallah Islam has come
down hamdulillah that we have Islam that
it gives us a guidance and a balanced
view and this is what one of the things
that's beautiful about Islam
it covers all aspects of your life the
only religion that handle our covers all
aspects of enlightenment from from going
to the toilet to eating - you're married
through issues you name it and it's come
to defend the honor of the believers and
we would do that and if it is proven
like I said before do go handle our deal
with it but don't you dare accuse
anybody anyone falsely
so that is the reason why I deleted
those tweets and from now on any kind of
allegations refer people back to this
video and leave the matter to the judges
and people that are qualified I thank
every single one of you guys may Allah
bless you all guys for watching this I'm
sorry I was a bit harsh and direct I
think it was deserved it was deserved
we've been very very soft and kind to
these brothers and sisters in this field
and tried to advise them never insulted
them always with kind gestures and we've
got nothing but arrogance and abuse I'm
so sorry so if this matter is cleared
inshallah and let's not be hypocrites
that we would like to be treated in one
way but ask other people to be treated
another way so next time from this
beautiful garden ceremony
come what a miserable okay